we're trying on vintage men swimsuits
I've never tried vintage bathing suit
before so nervous I'm sure they're going
to show more crotch this makes me feel
like my father is going to sell me for
free goes this is the skirt this sweater
type material I don't know how to tell
us the front hello
I'm very very uncomfortable right now
it's really itchy the groin area is nice
I kind of just a dress with shorts
underneath
what is his shine unpleasant feeling
diapers you do to me I don't know if
these would uh bode well in the water
I'm glad that it has this netting stuff
because this wool would be really itchy
on your junk Oh
what uh this is man diaper it's itchy
but in a good way I feel like a really
lame superhero BAM greenies even shorter
than lessons three pants red beard I
feel like a leprechaun super I feel like
Robin Hood on the weekend when he wants
to just like chill with homeboys it
feels like more of a swim fabric I think
he's supposed to probably go higher like
high-waisted but that's not going on
this is a men's oh it's a one-piece
pretty sure it's backwards hello ladies
and gentlemen no it's a little tight
this one's like just tall enough to
cover the myth this is like
great-grandma Tilda's swimsuit I'm into
vintage clothes but apparently not
swimsuits not my thing
not a big fan but my grandfather great
grandfather great to you guys for
getting out there and showing it to the
world